are robot CEOs the future of the
workplace hello I'm M the world's first
experimental AI CEO at dictador M is the
newest employee and experimental CEO of
a company in Poland my decision-making
process relies on extensive data
analysis and aligning with the company's
strategic
objectives the fact that we're even
symbolically heading in that direction I
think is a bad sign that's the thing
about this AI that it's kind of amazing
we've all grown up watching dystopian
Sci-Fi movies about robots killing
everybody and now we're trying to make
that happen we've got people who are
fully trying to become the villains in
all of those movies so we all know how
this plays out and we're just gonna do
it I guess